a man it's me a woke up at 6:00 a.m.
this morning like Christmas like it was
Christmas man because the Avengers
trailer was dropping and I knew it I
could feel it in my bones
I left a plate of cookies out for the
Russo brothers and oh did they deliver
oh they brought it man the good folks at
Marvel I'm just kunis em good folks at
Marvel gave us a gift this week earlier
with the Captain Marvel trailer then
they gave us this gift on Friday with
the Avengers trailer and they gave us a
title I'm gonna reveal it because maybe
you haven't watched it yet and stuff but
we're gonna watch it together oh I love
this trailer man they didn't pour a
bunch at us there wasn't like a [ __ ] ton
of montaging look at a [ __ ] world and
it focused on our core survivors haunted
by the snap or what they call in the
Marvel Universe the decimation I I
couldn't be ready for this I'm going to
make a movie in January February March
we're gonna make Jay and Silent Bob
reboot sequel to Jay and Silent Bob
strike back I've been talking about for
a while finally happening I am I
couldn't be more excited about that I'm
more excited about this this is what my
grandmother would refer to as her story
she would watch her soap operas and when
they were on The Young and the Restless
she was like everybody shut up my
stories are on and she'd lean in and
these are my stories
there's Marvel movies oh my god I
[ __ ] love them they make me so happy
Marvel's most stories Star Wars with my
stories DC when they got it right those
my stories I love this [ __ ] makes me
feel young especially in a turmoil
filled world nice to escape that's what
it's for it's escapism so anyway without
further ado [ __ ] let's dive in shall we
to this trailer man
it's a minor character study not minor
meaning minor characters but a minor
meaning it's only two minutes character
study in our first real glimpse at the
marvel universe post snap I thought that
was really interesting
like how everybody's dealing with it
let's let's dive in shall we let's let's
watch queue it up right now if you're
gonna watch it long you're gonna hear it
it's gonna be easy to cue up but I'm
gonna put this [ __ ] widescreen here we
go
Avengers oh I might reveal it they'll
reveal the time and we'll see it
together although I watched it already
called James alright here we go
start with the Iron Man mask and how
because he wasn't wearing a mask
is this all that's left of the nano
bites and stuff and he can put it
together in just the math that's why he
doesn't have any spots thing else on his
body if you find this recording Tony
lost in space don't feel better talking
to Pepper Potts part of the journey use
the end part of the journeys the end is
[ __ ] poetry director being adrift in
space for zero promise of rescue is more
fun that sounds rescue as a key word
here we'll talk about whether we know
for basically Tony talking you know to
nobody lost him on gravity
Tony Stark in gravity man I am talking
about him important very human story
Superman super hero super human the
human part is so important logo is about
to dissolve
how awesome was that that Oh scarecrow
just like in the comity Panos walk to
the field they didn't do a lot of spend
a lot of money on the face because they
just need his hand out 50% cap crying
all living creatures Black Widow emotion
Sheree was one of the people wiped out
from Black Panthers 50% of those
creatures means Pat's [ __ ] lost
friends lost family the more reference
there what up Ronan revealed man's the
blades come out the mass comes off as a
dead man as oh but finally on our lives
Maggie Carter plays world they're gonna
come back this time I think we all know
that nowadays cuz I don't know what I'm
gonna do if it doesn't almost opens pal
the Menace is sitting there watching
this morning like oh my god are they
gonna tell us the title and they did
[Music]
vengers endgame ladies and gentlemen and
that would have been enough but this is
magic look at I'd [ __ ] Spielberg caps
and shut on man it's like come on
I get so [ __ ] stupid emotional for
this [ __ ] little ant-man gonna save the
day
let's watch that again [ __ ] that was
amazing
I got a figure since like we last saw
Tony get the ship eat out and buy Thanos
and all of his nanotech list it's big
Thanos looked
Silent Bob with the Infinity Gauntlet
what satis t public done on this
recording I would watch this whole movie
of Tony Stark lost the Tracy and I love
Robert Downey jr. and that line part of
the journey is there anything in church
to space for zero professor rescue is
more fun that sounds my bet is that
Pepper Potts gonna come yet on a man out
in the rescue pseudo some people are
mine a long morning think it's gonna be
cap I don't things back yeah I think
peppers can sake tell me when I dress
off I will turn back you come on Mike
seems like setup for you but I love that
where these the end of the world he's
still thinking about pepper bucks
yes we here we go man oh that was like
no that better never happened we lose
Marvel Studios now
Bano scarecrows so [ __ ] never loved to
sing a nose did exactly what he said he
was gonna do benefit exactly what he
said he's been agreed he wiped out
they've shown us 20% precious little and
Stewart was the bait egg ant-man was
snapped out that they surely snapped out
that we lost Simone the places where
that
lost friends lost family oh come on man
you lost a part of ourselves
who's the Dead Guy
who they brought back Hawk online Conan
Peggy Carter plays a little mark Steve
look us look at how grim it is cuz I owe
you [ __ ] I love it I love it so much
[Music]
we're gonna we're watching title of
course man oh man
let's see if I get emotional and I've
watched the tail turn in fact with the
antenna
I just love that be visited hopeless
trailer until this moment [ __ ] is just
an old message oh and this doesn't even
include its Captain Marvel buzz man damn
man come the [ __ ] on I love that so so
much I can't wait Avengers of the
endgame I'm shook thank god I left those
cookies out for Santa Russo brothers cuz
man did they leave a sweet Christmas pre
Christmas tree
I'm just shook I'm ready I'm ready I'm
stayin alive for this I have to live to
this I've got to make a movie as well
then I got a live to [ __ ] see this man
hats off to Marvel make mine Marvel oh
my god I'm gonna go about the rest of my
day with spring my step I feel like I've
just come a thousand times there it is
thanks for watching
you